[Music]
hello and welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby and today
i want to introduce you guys or maybe uh
just at least show you guys some really
really fun stuff
in the marshall gambit now all of you
should have one question when i tell you
i am going to show you something in the
marshall gambit
and that question of course is which one
there's like eight marshall gambits
n and just to show you a few here before
we get into the real one for the video i
want to highlight
just some of the many marshall gambits
out there e4
d5 e takes d5 knight f6
this is the scandinavian of course and
some people call this line the marshall
gambit
of course there is the french defense
when after d5 knight c3 black can play
c5
and this is the marshall gambit
of course there's uh d4 d5
uh c4 e6 knight c3 c5
when this is known as the marshall
gambit
there's of course the roy lopez
sorry when you get to this position
and black plays d5 entering the martial
attack which gambits upon
not to be confused with any of the other
four martial gambits
and then there is the topic of today's
lecture
which goes d4 d5 c4
e6 knight c3 and now not c5
when white could take take and play e4
entering the marshall gambit
but instead c6 when black has built
a formidable triangle uh this
is called you know mostly called the
semislav
but with this particular move order i
like to call it the triangle
because black is very very clear about
what he's trying to do
he builds a triangle in the middle of
the board and now dares white
to uh to play a move and the reason of
this move order
for black is of course if you try to
enter the semislav
by playing first the slav then hoping
for knight f3 or knight c3
and then knight f6 and then e6 it's true
that you get to the semislav
but you have to deal with one little
move which i myself actually play
which is c takes d5 and so this move
order by black
is a very good way to get the semi-slab
to achieve the semi-slot
without first having to enter any
exchange law variations so
that's why you might see this move order
crop up and then of course if you play
net netflix here you're just playing a
qgd
not a semi-sloth so those semi-slot
players sometimes like to play the
triangle
and this actually gives white a little
bit of an issue here white has to make a
decision now between a few different
moves
the move e3 is perfectly playable but
you know
it's not always ideal for white to lock
in this bishop the move knight f3
seems perfectly natural as well but then
you have to contend with the insanely
sharp
note boom variation which i myself have
played a few
games in actually with both colors at
some point and it's never
never really gone well for me honestly
with either side but i found that
white has a really difficult time
actually getting this pawn back
and uh making use of his central
advantage or you of course
can play marshall gambit number five
with the move e4 and that's going to be
the topic
of today's lecture and this is a great
way to enter
some absolutely insane variations
right from the get-go black
should take on e4 accepting the gambit
the move bishop b4
is playable as well but i do think white
gets a pretty decent advantage
after the simple move c takes d5 e takes
d5
and e5 just with a nice central majority
uh white is going to have a good game in
this case
but that's not what i want to focus on
we're focusing on the marshall gambit
accepted
with d takes e4 of course white should
recapture this pawn
and everything seems to be going you
know quite well for white you know you
can imagine the move knight f6
next white could take take knight f3
bishop g5 is coming as a threat and you
know white has a pretty good game with
an extra
spatial advantage in the center thanks
to this pawn on d4
but of course there's a problem with
this line and that is the fact that
bishop b4 exists
now what's the big deal about bishop b4
check well
it's sort of an issue for white to
actually get out of check here
the move knight c3 is playable but then
the move c5
or knight f6 are both coming very very
quickly with immediate threats
to white's center and at the end of the
day it's going to be tough for white to
maintain
this central space advantage and
the natural move bishop d2 which is what
we're going to look at today
obviously has a drawback and that
drawback is the d
pawn is hanging hence we are in fact
gambiting something so bishop d2
queen takes d4 is the only move for
black here if you try something like
this
just queen takes and what white once
again has a nice advantage
so queen takes d4 bishop takes b4 and
now black picks up this
knight on e4 and white actually has two
different options to get out of this
check
of course we're not playing king d2 and
we're not playing queen e2 which leaves
us with either bishop e2
or knight e2 and they're both very very
reasonable moves
bishop e2 is sort of by far the main
variation
at higher levels but i think 92 is
actually a
a very very interesting way for white to
play and that's the line i'm going to be
recommending here today
so uh we are actually following a game
by the way between peter wells and oleg
korniv
korniev rather and
in that game uh peter does in fact
choose the move
knight e2 and now there's
two main moves that we're really going
to focus on here and then i
am also going to introduce um you know
sort of what happens if black just plays
a natural developing move like
knight e7 but the two main moves here
are in fact
knight to a6 challenging this bishop on
b4 and knight to d7 uh knight d7 of
course
just getting developed trying to gain
control of the c5 square
and blocking off this queen from axis to
d8
which is actually very very relevant so
in this game we're actually going to
start with
the less common move which is knight d7
knight a6 is by far i think sort of the
main variation
but i wanted to show you kind of the
character of some of the positions
with this game which went um knight d7
so what has white achieved by gambiting
this pawn
uh in the center right it's sort of a a
pretty substantial gambit here you know
stuff like the benko gambit which you
know a lot of people think is is even
unsound
black is gambiting like an a and a b
pawn for for a c
pawn right you know he's gaining in the
center with this gambit by forcing white
to to go away from the center
with this gambit white's center has
completely disappeared
so that means that well you know there's
the saying a pawn is a pawn
some pawns are more pawn than others and
giving up a d and an e pawn
is is a pretty substantial gambit here
white is going to have to get a lot
in return for it so what does white
actually have
well by removing the dark squared bishop
and developing sort of our
dark square bishop with tempo black is
going to have a very very difficult time
finishing development especially with
threats on
the dark squares in particular which is
how we arrive
at the next move of queen to d6
when all of a sudden you have to be very
careful about moving either of these
knights
sort of for for the rest of the game uh
and in this variation now uh black
actually has
a variety of options he can play the
move queen e5
immediately but it is a bit more
accurate to include the move a5 first
which is what was played in the game
basically the lines after queen e5 are
going to be very
very similar to the lines after a5 with
the exception that this bishop won't
have the option to retreat this way
because a5 essentially forces this
bishop back to
a3 in theory the bishop could come back
to c3
but white should really keep up these
threats along these dark squares in
front of the black king
now in order to break free black plays
the move queen e5
trying to sort of you know stem the tide
a little bit here you know
black's not really interested in getting
check muted immediately
and white of course uh could actually
consider
uh trading the queens i think this is
something that was
uh played a couple times but much better
is the move queen d2 in my opinion right
you're not playing the marshall gambit
to you know trade the queens right away
uh if your opponent is is playing like
this sometimes unfortunately it's
unavoidable
to get a queen trade but this is not one
of those times
so queen d2 keeping the queens on the
board of course
you know white's play is uh on the dark
squares he doesn't want to come to d3
blocking off potentially this bishop he
doesn't want to come to d1
because white is actually quite
interested in castling on the queen side
of the board
and black now tries to regain these dark
squares with the move
c5 and at first glance here it looks
like white's opening has
has sort of failed right this bishop is
looking quite sidelined on the a3 square
black is regaining control over the dark
squares with this powerful centralized
queen
and really what's going to stop black
from playing knight f6
b6 bishop b7 and kingside castles like
what what what is going to stop
black from doing this well chatroom i
want to see if you can figure it out uh
what move
do you think white should play here
there is a very very nice idea
by white in this particular position
yeah jacob says oh i thought this was
about the other marshall gambit
yeah at the top of the hour i i showed
that there are actually about
five marshall gambits so we're focusing
on the one in the semi-sloth
in russia it's called the slav gambit
which makes sense because it comes from
the semislav
why not push b5 b4
uh well for black it's really about
regaining control of the dark squares
so black isn't really interested in
trying to take over the b5 square for
example
it's more about shutting this bishop out
ariana thought it was about the one in
the royal lopez but yeah as i said it's
not even called the martial gambit in
the roy lopez it's just a gambit
in an attack okay i don't know if the
chat is going to get this one
many people would assume that the best
white can do is really just queen side
castle
then the game might continue something
like this something like g3 for example
castles bishop g2 and white is honestly
a bit worse in this position in my
opinion
white is sort of just down a central
pawn and black is going to be able to
finish development without too many
issues even a move like rk7
then b6 then bishop b7 it's all very
very reasonable
for white so what white should do is
immediately
challenge this queen on e5 whenever you
play these gambits
you always have to be thinking about the
most direct way to play
and then of course that's not always
correct but that's the first thing you
should consider
what are the most immediate threats i
can make to sort of force my opponent's
pieces back
into the position so in this case f4 is
the right way to go about it
and black actually only really has two
main options for
this queen turns out black's best move
is actually to put the queen all the way
back on the b8 square
what's the reason for that well anywhere
else the queen is actually going to be
vulnerable to
attack on c7 for example it has to
contend with a knight landing on b5
and hitting that queen with tempo on f6
for example
has to contend with the knight landing
on e4
and again hitting that queen with tempo
and also from f6 it's sort of in the way
of this night's development so that sort
of leaves
knight queen e4 why isn't queen e4
black's best move well once again knight
c3
is going to be coming with tempo and now
is not the time to sort of back away
with white
yes black is attacking your pawn but
what do you care right you already
sacked
one pawn why not sec another and queen
side castles is
a great way to play for an advantage and
that's actually what happened
in this game i should note that this
position by the way has only been
reached five times and this has only
been reached three
so it's not like we're in deep heavy
theory here this is uh
sort of already going to be both players
uh you know playing out of book playing
playing by their own brains as dmitry
komarov would say
and i got to be honest with you it'd be
really tough for me to come up with the
move queen b8
uh that being said it is the best move
so i want to take a look at it really
quick
uh for example here the game might
continue with queenside castles
peter wells by the way apparently plays
this a lot because he also has a game
from this position
and something like b6 trying to get
developed but then white is actually
going to go
for the king's side with a move like g4
and this is pretty much how this game is
going to go
white is going to try to push a little
bit on the king's side get this bishop
out to the g2 square and black is
basically just going to try
to survive and hold on to his extra pawn
by the way you can look for white to
play something like b3
and bishop b2 to sort of excavate this
piece
or maybe evacuate this piece from its
prison on
the a3 square but in this game we do see
queen e4
and white very uh you know accurately
queen side castles
uh black now made the mistake of trying
to develop with knight g
to f6 and of course now the move knight
c3
is going to come into the position
queen c6 was played and now the simple
move by white
bishop e2 and white is already
pretty close to winning in this position
why is white so close to winning
well it's because this queen has nowhere
good to go and
white has already gotten one tempo
against the queen and the second tempo
is about to come don't even think about
taking the g2 pawn by the way
bishop takes c5 and your day is going to
be pretty much ruined
day is going to be pretty much ruined
here um
black can no longer castle this cannot
be captured due to queen d8
checkmate and if you try something like
b6
i i mean really any move here but simply
bishop a3 rook hg one to follow and
black is busted
so don't even think about going pawn
grabbing if you're playing with the
black pieces
in the game black castle which is
probably the best try and white just
continues now with bishop f3
queen b6 and once again what should
white play
in this position it's one of those
positions where
again really any move is going to be
really really good
for white but i would like you guys at
home to try and come up with some of the
main ideas here because
while white does have i i am willing to
say no winning position it's
something like plus three um it's the
type of winning position
where if you don't play accurately for a
few moves
then black is very much going to be back
in the game right if you give black a
little bit of time
get those pieces developed black is
going to be right back in it
and quite potentially still with an
extra pawn so what should white be doing
here
yeah patrick daly is right on the money
here today
um you go with pawn to g4
black is up a pawn and white is plus
three yes y
is white plus three this knight cannot
move
except back to its starting square this
bishop literally cannot move
this knight cannot move except back to
the first rank
this rook i guess can come to d8 but
it's really only putting itself into a
pin
this rook cannot really move and this
queen
cannot really move right except to
retreat
and when actually none of your pieces
can move even a single square forward
aside from this rook which
i guess can that then you're just going
to be in trouble right
none of black's pieces can move here
none of them can move and in fact
black found the best move in the
position which is
knight b8 which kind of goes to show
just how bad things really are
um now moves like g5 are completely and
totally winning
rick he one is also winning as well just
activating the final rook
but white in this case decided why not
take the material back
and play the move knight to a4 queen c7
when the d6 or the c5 pawn is going to
fall
and in this case white actually chose
simplicity
over trying to get some checkmating
attack which is pretty instructive
in this case i think so many of you may
be unhappy with the next move that you
played
which is queen to d6 but it's actually
perfectly fine here
for white to play like this because
white is going to get a winning
advantage in this end game
it does throw away some of the you know
quote-unquote advantage
where it was sort of closer to plus
three now it's closer to plus two
but white is going to be winning and
white is really no longer running any
risks after this queen trade so black of
course should accept
takes takes and now the problem for
black is that he still really can't move
any of his pieces in the game he played
knight f to d7
rook h to d1 comes now rook a6 is trying
to trade
but now knight takes c5 rook takes d6
rook takes d6
takes takes and while pieces have sort
of disappeared from the board
white is left with the two bishops the
b7 pawn is
probably going to follow fall the rook
on d6 is very active
and these two pieces are still on on
their starting squares
24 moves into the game and they're gonna
stay there for a little bit longer
black played rook e8 stepping out of any
discoveries
bishop b6 was peter wells's choice a4
tries to keep this
pawn and now white just activates the
king
f6 king c3 now h4
bishop back to c5 when the king lands
here and i don't want to spend too much
time on this as it is
in openings class but yeah white finds a
nice little tactic here
with rook takes e6 don't even think
about taking that guy
bishop d5 is checkmate and with this
white was able to very easily convert
this end game
by the way move 35 and these pieces are
on their starting squares now
admittedly this knight got some ground
going back and forth but
still not very good for
black and then white easily won the end
game with this queen side majority i
just kind of skipped through the end
there
the fun bits were already gone so how
did this
actually happen well we saw that black
chose this sort of sideline with knight
to d7
white goes very naturally with queen d6
a5
forces this bishop back but now after
queen e5 white maintains the queens on
the board
and after c5 plays the very accurate
move of f4
when now black unfortunately just gave a
few too many tempo
too many tempe to white when white was
able to
activate all of the pieces while at the
same time really leaving black with
nowhere to move
and then it was only a matter of time
until white found some concrete way
to gain a material edge or at least a
positional edge
and win the game which is exactly what
happened in this case so
questions on this game before we move on
to one of the more
uh main lines instead of knight d7 i
just wanted to give you guys a feel
of some of the of the character of most
of the positions
you might be expecting to get with this
92 line
that was a pretty disgusting advantage
that white kept i tend to agree patrick
i tend to agree
all right well let's go ahead and move
right along i have another game to show
you guys
of course in the same variation between
artiom
team of feyev and dimitri frolianov
for leonov definitely and so here we go
d4
d5 c4 e6 knight c3
c6 black builds a mighty triangle
and of course white immediately tears it
down with the move e4
d takes e4 takes bishop b4 check
bishop d2 takes takes takes with
check and once again the move knight e2
uh now last game of course we saw knight
d7 which allows
the slightly awkward looking queen d6
for
black for for white rather and while
black does have this option of a5 and
queen e5 to force
the the white pieces back a little bit
we saw that white was able to develop
very quickly and hit black with a nice
little f4
which leaves this queen oddly stuck in
the center with no good place to move
in this case though knight a6 is
actually going to be the more common
move
and it's pretty easy to understand why
there's no real time for queen d6 now
black is going to be very very happy to
capture on the b4 square
so how should white respond to the move
knight a6 here chat
what do you think what could be played
your bishop is attacked
and yeah if you've seen it before of
course it is a really fun move
if you're sort of new to the position
you might not see it right away
but the right idea in this case is in
fact this
rather stunning move bishop f8
um don't think about capturing this
piece
because queen d8 is going to be
a devastating checkmate so
why bishop f8 well because why not and
also if you go to c3
then um i think the move f6 might be
playable to sort of stunt this bishop
out of the game for a little bit
whereas of course f6 not really going to
do anything about bishop takes g7 in
this case
so how should black respond to this uh
you know rather absurd move
turns out the move knight e7 is probably
the best way for black to handle this
and the point now is that king takes f8
still isn't a threat but rook takes f8
is and now white has to sort of um
you know pay his dues here he put his
bishop on a fate he's got to get that
guy back out
and he does so by capturing this pawn so
white
no longer down a pawn but what does
black have in return for it
well black is getting some threats of
his own and is sort of
able to evict a lot of these white
pieces and take back
many of his dark squares with moves like
knight f5 to follow
in many cases uh believe it or not there
are
actually two moves in this position and
i do want to get to the the move knight
b4 which is arguably
the main line but the move rook g8 is
almost as common and that's what i want
to start with here
and in the game i think timo feyev plays
uh well i know he plays the move queen
d4 and while this move
is sort of the main move here i think
it's actually slightly inaccurate
the reason for that is because if
possible
we would love to draw this rook to g6
and then play the move queen d4 trading
off
why do we want this rook on g6 well it
turns out the move
knight f4 is going to be very useful for
white and getting it with tempo
is sort of a lot better than not getting
it with tempo
we should say time is of course of the
essence in this opening and
any movie that you can play with tempo
is going to be really really powerful
so why don't people play bishop f6
well because the move queen takes c4
exists now queen 64 isn't even the most
common move in this position
but i think this is the reason why
people don't
do bishop f6 so i'm going to
go a little bit in depth into this queen
take c4 line because it's really the
only reason
not to play bishop f6 first but first
let's just take a look at what happens
in the game
we see queen d4 takes takes c5 hitting
the bishop
and then team of feyer tries to be
clever and comes to
bishop f6 now unfortunately for for
leonov
or fr for leona frolianov for leonov
uh he does play the move rook g6 which
is now just transposing
to on the line i wanted to play which is
something like this
when after c5 bishop c3 you would
achieve the same position
but of course there's no longer this
option to um
to play queen take c4 here so why isn't
what timotheave did
a bit better by going bishop f6 here
well
chat what do you think uh black could do
of course
uh well okay if you want to think about
it go ahead pause the video i'm just
going to tell you
but i can just play this move knight b4
and this is a little bit awkward for
white to deal with right there are a lot
of checks being threatened
and not a lot of solutions it turns out
white can go rook d1
but now after rook g6 bishop c3 is not
ideal
because knight takes a2 would now be
hitting this bishop
and so at this point white sort of has
to go in for bishop takes c7 or bishop
b5
and lose this dark squared bishop which
is going to be a very valuable piece
for white so this definitely is going to
be a better line for black i don't think
black is better here i think white is
still doing fine
but i don't think white is better either
at all which is why i really like this
move bishop f6
first and by the way i have played this
in a few games
and one of those games my opponent
played knight b4
who can tell me what's wrong with knight
b4
knight b4 is almost almost almost the
exact main line
of this variation so why not knight b4
here
and yeah ariane has the right idea black
is actually just checkmated
um queen d4 or sorry not queen d4 but
queen d6
and these two threats are impossible to
stop uh
you know you can give a check you can
take whatever you want over here well i
guess i should go to d2 rather
take whatever you want but there's no
stopping queen e7 and if this knight
moves of course
then queen d8 is going to be a pretty
good idea knight f5 queen d8
and black is immediately checkmated and
i've actually had a game
go like this against a not so weak
opponent by the way
so stuff like this you always should be
on the lookout for
if black plays a move you don't
recognize a lot of the time
black is just going to be lost so always
keep your tactical awareness
about you and be on the lookout for for
these kinds of opportunities
but this is not what happened in the
game instead
queen d4 first was played in the game so
why not bishop f6 first as i've said
it's this move
queen takes c4 and now i will give
a gold star to anybody in the chat who
can tell me what move
i am going to recommend after queen
takes c4
okay i highly doubt anybody in the chat
is going to be able to tell me the move
i recommend here
queen d6 and asked some questions and
then patrick says many questions
it's actually not very many questions
they're just very difficult questions
right
it's really only two questions queen e7
and queen d8 but
there are no so there are no solutions
yahayit says pawn b3 rook c1 knight d4
king d2
no nobody has it nobody has the best
move in the position
according to me queen d6
so queen d6 is actually how you can
arrive at what the real best move is
what's the problem with queen d6 right
it was checkmate last time
it's the problem now of course there's
queen b4 check
when queens come off the board and white
is now
down upon once again so
of course the move i recommended the
position great wolf
gets a gold star he's the first one to
say it with the move a3
and this understandably has never been
played but i did a bit of analysis here
and it's actually not so easy for black
to uh to equalize here there's really
only one line
that is finding full equality and that's
the move queen d5
uh now white can go knight c3 queen
takes d1 of course
by black rook takes d1 and unfortunately
for black
uh you know this is still a threat right
you know be it a queen or a rook
if something lands on d8 it's going to
be problematic for uh for black
uh black now of course though should try
to trade off a few more pieces with the
move knight d5
white is going to take this e takes d5
to activate the bishop
and now we get some end game with rook
g6 bishop c3
knight c5 king f2 a5
and g4 and this end game is actually
going to be
about equal i understand that it may be
difficult
to uh to see everything at this juncture
but white is going to have a lot of
activity with these bishops
this bishop can land on d3 it's going to
be targeting the king's side
very very thoroughly for black
well against black for whites and white
is going to have a pretty good time
pushing this h pawn up the board
and yeah this end game is just going to
be about equality and really this is the
only line
that black has after this move a3
which may not be you know the easiest to
find rook g6 is actually quite bad for
black after the move knight to c3
queen f4 we're actually going to take
the bish the knight on e7
and go g3 queen e5 check bishop e2
and simply castles and now this king is
stuck on e7
the major pieces are all still on the
board and white is going to have a very
fun time
going after this king here and white is
a bit better um
looks something like uh well actually
not too much better apparently uh most
of the lines i was looking at
ends up with being plus 0.5 if you give
the computer enough time to think so not
like white is winning or anything
but a nice little advantage
um instead of knight rook g6 if black
tries the very natural move knight to d5
the move bishop d4 is going to be fine
for white here e5
and rook c1 and we gain a number of
tempe
against this queen queen a5
and we get to regain our pawn as as well
so
a lot of fun variations here as well
after the move queen takes c4
which i think is really the only way for
black to get total equality
in this position and it's not like the
fun really ends there as
as i was saying but in the game we gets
this position with queen d4
c5 and bishop c3 but of course it was
arrived at
via the other move order with bishop
back to f6
and then back to c3 okay so black plays
the move knight b4 here which makes
a ton of sense there are three issues
that white needs to solve
and not very many ways to solve them and
in this position it's actually in
white's best interest to go ahead
and not take on b4
if this rook were on g8 then i think the
best that white could do
is take on b4 but since we drew this
rook out to g6
the very relevant tempo now comes into
play with the move knight f4
and after knight f4 white is going to be
a bit better
okay why is white a bit better well if
you play knight c2 check
king d2 knight takes a1 knight takes g6
hg6 and now the move bishop e2
and there is a game here that went
bishop d7
rick takes a1 bishop c6
but after g4 white is just going to have
sort of the bishop pair for free
and not only that white has a very
distinct plan of creating past pawn on
the h
file which by the way when white is
controlling the h8 square
that's not going to be the most fun
thing in the world for black to deal
with
and i think the computer gives something
like like plus one in this position
but in the game we actually don't see
the move knight c2
which would be really the only
refutation if there was one
instead we get the move uh rook to g5
and here white kicks the rook around
again with the move h4
and now after rook f5 we get a very
interesting idea
by white here which is the move knight
d3
and many of you were probably wondering
well you know it's great that we attack
the rook but what does white
do if the knight is actually going to
get attacked by the rook
sort of counter-attacked by the rook and
the answer is we just move it
and this is now actually an exchange
sacrifice
by white at the very least right an
exchange sacrifice assuming
we regain this piece here on a1 which
likely we will
but for the moment that's a full rook so
what's the justification
for this sacrifice what can white do
here
so yeah simon has the right idea this
rook is running very very very
short on squares after the move g4 so it
doesn't turn out to be a true sacrifice
in this case
because there's absolutely nowhere to go
besides the square f3 when after bishop
e2
rook takes d3 bishop takes d3 and now
white once again
is very very close to that dream end
game
with the two bishops against the bishop
and knight and in this time
not the ability to make a past h pawn
but a very distinct weakness over here
on the h7 square in the game e5 was
played
and white doesn't actually take this guy
because of course g4 is hanging
so f3 was played now f5 by black is
challenging the g
pawn once again and white just pushes
forward with g5
and now there are always going to be
threats of white making a past pawn
right here on the king's side and this
is actually what white uses to
eventually win this game black played
with a very
uh with a great amount of activity
though playing the move e4
and then white finds a rather stunning
move here actually
which is not to take on e4 which maybe
this was simpler and in my opinion
probably just a bit better but he plays
the move bishop f6 instead which you
gotta love the guy for it
you know take my bishop rookie one and
regaining
this guy over here on e7
and it's some complications but the
tactics do actually work out so after
bishop f6
black tried to move b5 and now white
just takes on e4
takes on a1 and this end game is is
rather hopeless
for uh for for black you actually see
rook d4 trying to get white to capture
on d4
white of course is winning if he does
but you know in this case
uh timothev wasn't even tempted b takes
c4 was played
and now after bishop a4 check king d8
this is actually the the saddest
position i've ever seen i think this
wins
the saddest position of all time award
uh it's not an easy award to win but but
this is it that this is
it does not get sadder than this so uh
think on this position when you are you
know in some bad position suffering
it doesn't get worse than this for black
why doesn't it get worse for this well
after h5
black plays c3 white finally takes this
exchange
we see check and white takes the rook
back
but then after takes bishop d3 um
first of all g6 this cannot be captured
because
queens so e3 and then first of all
bishop b5
this cannot be captured because then
white queens then after bishop b1
bishop f6 black is never
able to remove this root to move his
king or his knight ever again
the king and the knight both just they
can't move
ever again they can never move they're
done moving for the rest of the game
and that is why black is dead
so in the game they played on a few more
moves hg6
h6 and then after king e2 black just
resigned because
this piece can't move this piece can't
move
this piece has to stay on this diagonal
and really there's there's not that many
more pieces for for black to play with
here
so this is um
sort of one of the main two variations
after knight
a6 right this stuff with queen d4
and what do you need to know to play
this well 97 is sort of forced
and rook g8 is one of the main lines i'm
recommending bishop f6
if you get the move rook g6 which i i
think by far this is going to be the
most common move you're playing against
then queen d4 gives white a nice
advantage
after the main line when you can insert
this move
knight to f4 by the way what happens on
rook h5 well that means knight
h5 with more threats right back to g5
you
still get this check something like king
f8 then
you can just go bishop e2 so that's why
no rick g4
and after h rook g5 h4
um and yeah i'm sorry
somehow messing up the variations in
leeches but that's okay rook f5 and then
knight d3 is a nice little
uh temporary exchange sacrifice with g4
to follow
uh and if your opponent happens to be
super super booked up
after queen takes c4 white is not worse
at
all you can actually play knight c3 or
knight g3 here and i don't think white
is worse in either of those variations
but i'm recommending the tricky move a3
the point being you're threatening
queen d6 in many cases now because
there's no more queen b4
check in order to equalize what black
should play the move uh queen
d5 and now after knight c3 takes takes
knight d5
takes takes f3
boop-ba-doop knight c5 for example
a5 and g4 and you get an equalish end
game where white is going to be pushing
on the king's side and trying to target
this h7 pawn
uh as compensation for the for the d
pawn and it's about equal okay any
questions on this one
so yeah if you don't like this bishop f8
move unfortunately then i would
recommend
you play um
i would recommend you actually play the
bishop e2 lines
uh and i think that's going to get you
the positions that you want
so if you go bishop b2 here knight a6 is
still the main move
and then the main move is is bishop a5
or bishop d6 so i think you should go
bishop b2
if you don't like bishop f8 uh with
knight e2
well i think you technically can go like
bishop a5 or bishop d6 or something i
think black is usually actually ending
up
on the better side of things but yeah
bishop b2 here is actually the main move
by white
and if you don't like bishop f8 in those
lines then i would recommend you go
for bishop e2 instead
[Music]
how is g4 better than g3 bishop h3 well
in the game continuation g4 was better
because it immediately won the material
back
right if you go g3 it's it's a bit slow
right
this rook can maybe save itself with
something like e5 but g4
attacks the rook immediately the rook
has nowhere to go and then it
immediately has to give itself up
for a knight um okay
so that is this move um 10
rook g8 and that is really one of the
two
main variations in this opening that you
should know
if you are going to play it practically
for yourself right
so we've looked at the sort of sideline
with knight d7 which leads to some
really crazy stuff
and now we've looked at essentially half
of this move knight to a6 you go bishop
g7
and this move bishop f6 is what i'm
recommending with the idea
of a3 after queen c4 and knight c3 to
follow
and just simple development for white
ending in
an equal end game and of course if rook
g6
just to recap we go queen d4 and this
line
is a bit better for white with this nice
idea of knight f4 okay moving on let's
check out the main main variation
uh of this opening which i am going to
do by showing you an example game
between uh wodazek is how i'm
choosing to pronounce it and of course
the one and only anish
geary
ben simon coming in with a save here i
guess he's tired of listening to me
struggle with all the names
uh as is everybody i'm getting a lot of
youtube comments about how disrespectful
i am for not being able to pronounce
names and languages i'd never spoken
which you know that's tough
of course we have the marshall gambit
once again the one from the semislav
d takes e4 should be for check bishop d2
takes on d4 takes takes with check
knight e2 is the line
i am covering today knight a6 still the
main move
bishop f8 knight e7 bishop g7
and then rather than save the rook which
of course is a very natural idea
by black the main variation for black is
actually this move
knight to b4 and this is normally the
best way
for black to try to equalize what is the
idea of knight b4
well the idea is you are countering
bishop takes h8
with your own idea of
uh actually the move e5 first which you
you might not expect
and sorry i didn't fully prep this
variation i just know it's a forced draw
queen d6 by white would be the idea then
knight c2 check king d2
bishop f5 is the only move for black
knight g3 and you end up in some
ridiculous four straw knight d5
check is the move cd5 queen d4 and
draw agreed right this is sort of the
best way of playing if bishop takes h8
so if you ever want to draw somebody
with the white pieces and you find
yourself staring down this position
take this rook play queen d6 and you've
got yourself a draw
of course though i want to try to play
for a bit more than a draw with the
white pieces
and so you can play this move queen d6
instead
uh after queen d6 it is very much in
black's best interest to play knight d3
check
knight c2 check has been played before
but i think white is a bit better
after king d2 knight takes a1
and bishop takes h8 queen c2 check can
be played but now king e1
and this king is surprisingly resilient
on the e1 square
uh there's a game between uh nikita
vichugh and ray robson
that went like this but the move f3 here
uh
is going to be fine for uh for white
in that game black actually ended up
winning but after f3 white is very much
a bit better
uh knight g6 for example bishop f6 and
threats something like h4 here
uh queen f5 for example i don't want to
get too into this but basically
this this line is is fine for white um i
didn't prep this one too thoroughly
because
you don't really see knight c2 check
that often and it is kind of bad for
black
if if white plays pretty accurately so
knight d3 check is the move i
want to cover because i feel like that's
the move you guys are actually going to
be facing
because it's uh the best way for black
to actually equalize in this opening
of course we should go king d2 not king
d1 stepping into checks
and now the move here for black is
actually the move knight
f5 attacking two pieces at the same time
pretty tough queen takes d3 is forced by
white
and now we end up in an end game
and this end game is i'm not going to
lie to you
about equal right it's tough to say that
white really has any advantage here
but i do think practically black is
going to be the one
with problems to solve still this knight
on g7
for the moment looks like it could
easily come back to f5 but after king's
c3
stepping off the d file and off of this
diagonal
b6 white's idea is to actually play this
move g4
and this does give black some practical
issues
with bringing this knight back into the
game
for example bishop b7 bishop g2 queen
side castles
rook a to d1 c5
uh is the main move sorry but that's not
what was played here uh
after rook 8 d1 by the way this exact
position has been reached
uh five times in the database i'm using
and white managed to win
uh one of those games with the other
four games
being drawn so i think practically it's
it's fair to say
white has uh you know a few more chances
right because of this knight on g7
because black is not totally totally uh
without problems yet i think practically
white does have
uh a small chance at least of of winning
this game
and of course it's not like there's no
play left in the position
uh even in in practically equal
positions some
somebody usually can end up winning at
most levels of chess
and i think there's there's a lot to to
play for here with white right this
knight is still stuck here these pawns
are a little bit
weak and yeah there's just a lot of play
left in the position but unfortunately
if you are
uh voter jack voters
then um you know you're 2700 plus you're
playing a niche gary who's also
you know 27.50 pretty decent they're
probably gonna draw this game
um h5 was gary's choice in the game
trying to immediately solve the problem
of this knight and so
votajek plays the move g5 we see c5
takes on b7 was played and now knight f4
and again practically this pawn is a bit
weak but you know white has his own
weaknesses as well
in the game knight f5 was played takes
on d8 takes on d8
takes on h5 but now rook g8 comes after
the g pawn and after h4 rook h8 knight
g3
black regained this pawn and the game
was drawn without too much more
controversy
a few more moves were played they
shuffled around a bit traded off some
pawns
and at the end of the day you get
glorious night versus night
when they did in fact decide it was time
to stop playing
um so this is really just the main line
of the variation now while it is the
main line
black does have to be reasonably booked
up in order to to get to the end of it
right
so i think practically in many of your
games you're never going to make it this
far
i know i rarely actually make it to
this exact end game line in the games i
have played
in this opening and so while it can be a
little bit disheartening
to learn that the main line is actually
just going to be fine for black
you know tough luck turns out that's
pretty much every opening in chess
right and if you're unhappy with
endgames
maybe this isn't the line for you but
you get to have a lot of fun along the
way
and you know who doesn't love playing
bishop f8 right
who doesn't love playing bishop f8 so
any questions on this game
and then with the remaining time i want
to take a look at a few more
uh games where of course
black deviated early from the mainline
stuff because it's always useful to see
some examples of how play can continue
if they're not playing you know this
this deep
theory why is there a percent next to
the ratings i think that was a mistake
with uh me copying over the pgn
okay
why doesn't black move the knight right
away before g4 is played that's a good
question
um well after king c3 if you go knight
f5
i think g4 would be played anyways when
this knight
doesn't have the greatest squares to go
to if it goes to e7
now all of a sudden i think bishop g2
might be a good move
for white the idea being
you get to this diagonal first and uh
maybe maybe what's a bit better although
i think this is
sort of playable maybe another issue is
actually that this is
sort of coming rather rather quickly
right like let's say you play b6 like
the normal stuff
now knight h5 and yeah this this might
this knight might just uh
might be landing on f6
so yeah it just costs black a little bit
too much time white plays g4 anyways and
sort of activates the pieces stuff like
bishop g2 is coming as well
rook d1 and white just sort of getting
there first so black
prioritizes finishing development
getting to the d file rather than
fixing the knight on g7 right away it's
a good question though it's a good
question
what is black's best option yeah i think
this is black's best way
to equalize pretty much in every other
line i've
looked at black does have some practical
problems right in this rook g8 rook g6
line that i looked at
i think white is actually just strictly
worse and with this bishop f6 move that
i'm recommending
it's not a total novelty but it is
rather rare and i
sincerely doubt most of your opponents
are going to be familiar
with it and this queen takes c4 move is
really the only way for black to
equalize there
and then after a3 i think queen d5 is
again
pretty much the only way to fully
equalize so black is going to have to
find a couple really tricky only moves
if they go for this rook g8 variation
whereas with knight b4
if they play the theory they're gonna be
fine they're gonna get this
end game but okay let's take a look
at some sidelines i wanted to take a
look
at us uh women like
nine-time champion nine-time u.s women's
champion something like that
i don't know the exact stats maybe ben
simon can help me out here
but of course i am talking about irena
crush
a true mainstay mainstay in uh
you know chess and women's chess in the
united states over
you know the past however many years and
so we are looking at her game
against one igor novikov not a pushover
himself
at the time of the game irena was
actually rated under 2400 and novokov
was was just about 2 600. so irina the
definite underdog here
and let's see how her game turned out
against novikov she plays the move
d4 d5 c4 e6
knight c3 c6 e4 take take
check block take take take knight e2
because she knows what's good knight a6
bishop f8
and here black deviated early of course
i was saying 97 is
is really the only move but i wasn't
really saying why
so why can't black sort of play for more
with this
tricky looking move queen to e5 this of
course
defends the g7 pawn and perhaps now
um black is going to be interested in
making some threats about
actually taking this bishop in the near
future so
how do you think white should continue
if black plays some move
like queen to e5 here
patrick wants to play f4 again and
that's not
quite along the right track here
because in this case f4 i think would
actually serve to
push our opponent's queen to a better
square i think black would be very happy
playing the move queen to f6
when once again the move king takes f8
is going to be a legitimate threat
so the last time we saw the move f4
against queen of
queen e5 it was a great idea because the
queen had no good squares to go to
in this case f6 is a good square to go
to
so f4 doesn't make as much sense
queen d6 says alex hello to alex
tuning into the stream and no queen d6
you do
not not not want to trade off these
queens here we're trying to checkmate
black
but queen d6 is along the right track
actually because
of course what white wants to do is put
this rook behind this queen
play the move queen d8 and end the game
so that leads you sort of to the correct
move which is queen d2
keeping the queens on the board and very
much preparing to make a threat with the
next
move black's idea is in fact to play
queen f6 whether we force him to with f4
or not king takes f8 is now a threat and
white's just going to be happy to
retreat this bishop in this case
you know it may look like white wasted
some time with bishop f8
back to d6 but black also wasted two
full moves playing queen e5 and queen f6
and not only that this queen as in the
previous positions that we looked at
where it goes to f6
is vulnerable to tempo gaining moves by
the knight
and this is why black is actually a bit
worse off here
this queen is not comfortable on the f6
square
97 is the natural idea by black and what
black has achieved
is he's gotten this knight off of the
back rank and he's made castling legal
and he has not given up his g7 pawn to
do so
however it's not all sunshine and roses
for
novikov after the move knight g3 very
natural move
getting the knight out to the king's
side and getting ready to pressure this
black queen
on f6 black does go ahead and castle
and then irina makes a slight mistake
here that that gives away some of her
advantage but but not all of it
it turns out the best idea for white was
actually to come to this e5 square
or h5 square rather than the e4 square
the move knight h5 is is actually quite
strong here queen h4 is really the only
square
and then after bishop e2 you have to be
very very careful that this queen isn't
going to get trapped
in addition to that white of course is
going to follow up with moves like queen
side castles
by the way g3 is always a threat now in
order to
undefend this knight on e7 and white has
a very decent attack but let's stick
with the move played in the game which
is the move
knight e4 black comes out to h4 and now
white plays the move
queen to d3 or bishop to d3 uh
in the game black tries this move f5
but it's already sort of a lost cause
black's position is
is sort of terrible at this point irena
finds a great move which is g3 this is
the idea to undefend this knight on e7
queen g4 was played in the game and now
white to move and win see what you can
find chat see if you can find what irina
missed irena played a good move played a
move that gives her
a very good advantage but there is a
move that just
really strictly wins the game in this
position so white to move and win
what do you guys think
wait to move and win
so h3 runs into the move queen f3 i
believe when the rook on h1
is undefended and black is gaining a
crucial tempo
so chess king finds the move that irena
crush found in the game
which is to just take the knight right
you can take the knight take the rook
and be up the exchange which is exactly
what happens in the game
but it turns out white actually has
better
white can play the stunning move knight
to g5 and this
incredibly is making two threats at the
same time
threat number one is to take a knight
for free
threat number two if you defend this
knight believe it or not
is bishop e2 when the queen is totally
trapped nowhere to go
for the queen all of the squares totally
defended for white and black is just
dead lost
so the best black can do is rook d8
giving up this free piece when now
um white is is of course just really
going to be
sort of crushing the position right just
sort of crushing
uh in the game though bishop takes c7
was played f takes e4
bishop back to e2 gains time and then
bishop takes f8 and kingside castles
and then unfortunately because novakov
is a strong grandmaster
he managed to hold this uh position down
the exchange
uh although i i do think it should be
winning for irena with
uh you know better technique uh than
what she showed here
in this game uh i don't want to go
through the the rest of it
this is just an openings lecture and
it's pretty clear to me
that white has succeeded in this this
particular opening
so what can you take away from this game
in particular well when
black is playing these sort of sidelines
if they play something you don't
recognize
you can just sort of look for ways to
create tangible threats in the position
in this case
queen d2 was the key move after queen e5
in order to create these threats of rook
d1 with checkmate along the d
file after queen f6 we saw white retreat
this bishop back to d6
sort of playing patiently and then
knight g3 coming with tempo against the
queen
is a really critical idea in many
different variations
in this opening and with that i am going
to call it a day here on chess openings
explained
thank you guys so much for joining me uh
as always uh
let me know what your favorite martial
gambit is let me know what your favorite
martial gambit is as there are so many
of them uh me personally i think this is
one of my favorites
uh for sure at least top five right at
least this is a top
five martial gambit um but anyways
that does it for chess openings explains
if you are watching live
be sure to head over to the twitch
channel for tactics time
where the fun will be continuing tonight
if you're watching the youtube version
uh the youtube playback version rather
thank you so much for joining me
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you